the country all right two developments  here on this first of all on the  wilmington delaware event peter ducey  says a law enforcement source  familiar with tonight's planning tells  fox if there's a race call by 10 pm  biden and harris plan to speak at 11 30  p.m  outdoors if there is not a race call by  10 pm biden will appear so low  in the 11 pm hour indoors the other  development is from the supreme court  victor  and this is an order from justice alito  mandating the pennsylvania  all the ballots received after 8 p.m on  election day be segregated  and secured and quote all such ballots  if  counted be counted separately there is a  petition on the merits still pending  before scotus  justice alito has ordered the opposing  side the democrats to file a response  by 2 p.m tomorrow this is the supreme  court taking action